[MUSIC PLAYING]
So there's a great essay called
"The Genomic Bodhisattva,"
and it chronicles the work of
philosopher David Pearce, whose
"hedonistic" imperative
is the treaties that
calls for the abolition
of human suffering using
a cocktail of new
nanotechnologies
and psychopharmacologies to
reverse-engineer subjectivity,
hack perception to create
gradients of bliss,
ecstatic transcendent
mind spaces
of imagination
unbounded that would
make our day-to-day
existence seem trivial,
prehistoric by comparison.
These new modalities and these
new languages of experience
will be accompanied by states of
cognitive ecstasy, exhilarating
neuro-storms of intense
intellectual pleasure.
Every moment will
be autopoietic.
It'll be like creating God.
And it just sounds so
freaking exhilarating.
And this notion that
human beings seem to have,
this attachment to
suffering, this belief
that it adds character
and so on and so forth.
I get it, but I don't know.
There's something kind of
alluring to think that we might
be able to create possibilities
for ourselves, dimensions
in which this thing of
suffering no longer exists.
Just a thought.